hey everyone good to meet all of you
it's awesome to be here at by data being
here in Eindhoven in the Netherlands so
thanks to all the organizers actually
for setting this up and thanks for
inviting me um so I'm gonna try to talk
a bit about some of the research work
that I do I'm hoping that I'll strike
the right balance to between kind of
somewhat of a technical talk and
somewhat of a popular talk popular not
in the in the sense that you're gonna
like it but it is for general audience
so I'll give that a try before I dig
into it all just a bit of background
about myself so I'm out captain I'm a
professor of data science at yacht's the
euronymous academy of data science which
itself is a collaboration between the
University of Eindhoven and the
University of to Berg
so that's where I work I run a lab of
about 10 PhD students there and it's
gonna my daily my daily work I'm also a
co-founder of a company called scalable
where we effectively use web assembly to
put some machine learning models into
production I won't actually be talking
about that I'll pretty much be talking
about some of my research work so that's
that's the aim for today hope you enjoy
it I have this annoying coughs oh sorry
about that every now and then it's gonna
pop up my apologies um so I'm just gonna
start by talking to you guys and I'm not
showing an awful lot of pictures I have
some pictures here and there but mostly
I'll talk um and I wanted to introduce
kind of the main topic of this talk
which I would call data science methods
or machine learning or AI whatever you
want to want to call them for
personalization and and just by a show
of hands who has some idea of what what
personalization would would be basically
yeah well um so I think it's an
interesting thing that um in a lot of
fields so kind of in business but also
in healthcare in marketing in a lot of
places people talk about personalization
use the word you know quite colloquially
and quite informally as this idea that
if we interact with people where I'm
taking interact as quite a broad term so
interact might be sending you message
it might be talking to you it might be
administering medical treatments to you
I'm someone somehow doing things to
people that if you want to do that well
you might need to do different things
for different people that's kind of I
would say the informal idea of what
personalization would be at least for me
so that means that if I have some
objective of you know communicating with
all of you and have some goal that all
of you buy my product and have multiple
messages that I could send that I could
start here like in the front left all
the way up to the back and I can talk to
each and every one of you and it might
not need to say the exact same thing to
everyone to be as effective as possible
yeah that's what I say is what
personalization is and that is the
problem that I'm kind of going to talk
about today I'm going to talk a bit
about the different ways in which we're
treating that problem and some of them I
would say very cool to your radical
problems that pop up once you start
considering that problem I hope that's
somewhat interesting I see most of you
look somewhat skeptical I hope that's
just lunch kicking in and we're gonna
have some fun um so before talking about
personalization and some of the ways of
actually doing that let's define the
problem just just a bit more so here
it's just a simple description with
black lines through it because of this
grid but really the aim of what I'm
gonna talk about today is this idea of
oh I line all of you guys up
so that's units 1 to n where you know in
some conceptions of this problem I might
know and in some conception sure I don't
but but at least there's this idea that
I have units people that I can see
properties off so I could see that you
were wearing glasses I can see that
you're on the front row I can see
properties of you guys one by one I can
potentially interact with you people so
do something send a message you know
administer some people do something and
in the end I have a goal so with each
unit I want to achieve some goal maybe
you buy this product and what my main
aim of personalization would be acid by
the time I get to the the end there on
the right that I've sold as much as
possible of cue or cured as many people
as possible I'm just going to talk about
this problem more generally yes
units that have properties that I'm
interacting with I'm gonna see some
outcome and I want to maximize that
outcome over all those units that kind
of clear everyone I hope that sounds
like an interesting problem that's
applicable at least in a number of cases
and before digging into some potential
solutions to that problem
um let's first kind of think a bit more
about what would be useful to know if
we're talking about this problem so one
way of thinking about this problem is
the following that actually I have some
idea about but you sorry you're you're
right here in the phone so I'm going to
point at you quite a few times I have
some idea about like your glasses your
situation there's stuff that I can know
about you that I cannot necessarily
change and then there's these things
that I can do to you you know so if I'm
thinking about this problem or actually
what I'm concerned with is some some
functions some mapping of these things
that I do not control that are just
presented to me as a decision-maker some
things that I do control so some actions
that I can take and some some outcome
basically and I would say in theory if I
would know the relationship of the stuff
that I don't control the actions that I
can take to the actual rewards or
outcome so if I know kind of how those
functionally relate then in a sense this
problem of personalization is quite
simple because then for each and every
unit I the only thing that I would have
to do which might still be gonna
computationally complex or whatever but
the only thing that I interior need to
do is just kind of evaluate all the
different actions that I could take see
which one gives me the highest reward to
the highest outcome I'll do this for
each unit and I just arc mechs my action
I just do the action at SG is outcome if
I do this for each and every unit here
I'll get the highest outcome overall so
the problem of personalization is
actually super simple if I know the true
relationship between your kind of
between the situation your properties
and the actions that I can take and the
outcome I just pick whatever I would
like I pick whatever action has the
highest outcome so then it's pretty much
solved except that's gonna okay for
everyone
yeah the annoying thing is I have
another 30 minutes or something in this
stock so there must be more to it than
just actually doing this um and actually
the more to it obviously comes from the
idea that well this might in some ways
work interior it might still be
computationally complex but at least
theoretically this might be doable and
practice we have actually have a very
different situation we don't know how
these inputs or this context and the
actions actually relate to these
outcomes um we don't know like the
functional form of this I mean is using
this it's like someone abusing
statistical heavy notation for
estimators like we don't know the
functional form we might not know some
of the parameters involved we need to
learn this relationship and now suddenly
it becomes much more tricky um and just
before we dig into then how we could
effectively learn this relationship
please be aware of the fact that
although the relationship between kind
of the rewards on one side and the
context and the actions on the other
side might look like a supervised
learning problem because effectively I
just said input so the context and the
actions and output rewards so it might
look like a supervisor but I hope
everyone is familiar with supervised
learning with the term and some ways of
fitting each time small so I guess all
of you know some ways of finding this F
for finding these values of data that
work for this problem um you want to be
very explicit that this problem is
slightly harder than just the supervised
learning problem and it's by virtue of
the idea that I will have data of you
responding to one specific action but
I'll never have the data of you in the
exact same point in time with the exact
same context responding to the other
actions like there's only one action
that I can take in some sense for a unit
for specific context so it's probably
slightly harder than the supervised
learning because of the improvement of
what I would call counterfactuals like
we don't know what would have happened
if we had done something so I'm going to
talk a bit about how to not necessarily
solve this problem with some intuitions
for how to address it in practice and
kind of some of the things that I would
say are fundamental when thinking about
this problem and thinking about how to
solve it
and I'm going to do so in two distinct
situations where one situation is the
one that I was kind of talking about
when introducing it is what if I have
the opportunity to for each unit choose
some action see the outcome and then
move to the next unit so I have this
opportunity in some ways to experiment
which might be true in some business
contexts have the opportunity to
experiments how do I go about learning
this function but not just learning this
function but also making sure that by
the time that I get to the no Beck right
guy going there I'm dead I've made you
know as much reward as possible that's
the first issue I'll consider and then
second I'll talk about a slightly
different guise of this problem where
somebody whoever that might be
gives me some data of a bunch of Units
two actions that they received and the
outcomes that were observed so I get a
data set but I didn't actually make that
data set myself nor might I know exactly
how it came about so I might not
necessarily know how the actions were
chosen in their data set so we're going
to talk a bit about can we dance still
and like up to what level can we still
try to address that problem with that
data set that's somewhat interesting
yeah she's nodding cool thank you thank
you um so that's what that's what I'm
gonna do let's dig in to the first one
first so this idea I could start
experimenting so I can start with you
then go to you see your background
characteristics choose some action see a
reward and go through the whole kind of
go through the whole audience
sequentially yeah now let's think about
this problem by effectively making it as
simple as possible but still interesting
so if there was only one action to take
clearly the problem is not super
interesting because yeah that's just the
thing you would be doing however if we
have two actions that we could take and
we kind of ignore the context so in some
ways I'm gonna ignore personalization
I'm gonna ignore the guy the fact that
you guys are different there's going to
treat all of you as the exact same I
have two actions I'm gonna assume
they're some stick
drastic outcome so there's some outcome
some expected outcome and there's some
noise around it for each of those two
actions and so if actions a and B maybe
and you know one has a higher
probability of success than the other
that's a way of thinking about that
problem now we've stripped the problem
of a lot of complexities because
obviously we've made the action space
very small we ignored the whole context
we made the rewards you see on one with
some probability like we've kind of
really narrowed the problem down but
it's still sufficiently interesting I
think to think about this so that
problem where you one-by-one choose
between a and B two versions will have
some outcome with some probability is
what is known to some of you probably
already I don't know where it's known to
most of you as what's called the
multi-armed bandit problem who's aware
of this term just raise your hands those
of you are that's cool to hear I'm so
the multi-armed bandit problem as
effectively this slot machine problem
where instead of units as people I'm
just talking about rounds that I can
play a slot machine so I have one one
person to the end person have one round
to the end round I have multiple slot
machines in its simplest case just two
and one has a higher probability of
paying off than the other and what we're
interested in is given a often some fix
but it might be some infinite amount of
money what is a good strategy of
actually playing these slot machines
such that I make as much money as
possible and the core of why this
problem is challenging is not choosing
the slot machine that pays out the most
if I would actually know this so if I
would know this model what I started
with in this talk it was very simple I
just choose whatever has the highest
expected value why this problem is
interesting because I need to learn
which one is best but I also want to
play the one that's best as often as
possible
yeah so one potential strategy of kind
of attacking this problem if I'm talking
about all of you guys in a and B again I
would say well I'm gonna assign half of
you treatment a and half of your
treatment B that will give me a bunch of
data that will then allow me as
precisely as possible given the size of
you know by number
units here given my size of the
population to estimate these two means
but now I've also kind of administered
the wrong treatment to half of you so
that doesn't seem like the best thing to
do on the other hand if I only try a for
you and you you buy whatever I was
trying to sell I try B for you you don't
buy and then UA for everyone well now
I'm using the knowledge that I have
but maybe I'm kind of over confident in
this knowledge to them maybe I should
have learned more so the core of that
problems was called the exploration
versus exploitation problem I want to
learn which action is best but I also
want to earn based on my knowledge so I
wanna I wanna trade of those two and
effectively what we're looking at is
what I'd call decision policies decision
policy is just being mappings of all the
information that I have up to some point
in time where time is these units that
I'm discreetly like iterating true so if
all this data that I've collected and
that's gonna effectively dictate what is
my next action gonna be I'm gonna look
for different policies and see how well
they fare when I evaluate them on this
whole population so our main aim in this
problem is to find a policy that
effectively balances this exploration
and exploitation in this case so let's
let's think of some policies that that
might be reasonable or that might work a
very simple one is obviously I guess
came to everybody's working on a web
context when I was talking about version
a and version B one potential way of
trying to solve this problem is by doing
what's called an a/b test so taking a
subset of you guys randomly assigning a
and B then seeing in which of those two
groups that have the highest outcome and
that's what I'll use for the remainder
of these people this is something that's
known as a/b testing in the web world it
is you know with some some abuse known
as the randomized control trial in the
medical world where we try to treatments
but then obviously you you do have to
consider the fact that after the trial
we create some guideline and that's what
we use for the remainder because the
policy dictates what you do for everyone
not just for the people in the trial so
these policies are always some trial and
then
choosing whatever is best clearly also
by the way this specification of the
policy is not necessarily complete
because it doesn't really dictate when
do I move from exploring in the
beginning which is what I'm doing during
the test to exploiting that knowledge
like how many units am I gonna explore
oh that's that's gonna be an open
question in some sense when dictating
this a B test um but I don't want to
dick too much into that question what I
actually want to make clear is that
doing all the exploration first and then
moving to exploitation it's just one way
of sort of trying to solve this problem
there are many other ways one that is
very reasonable often and I hope easy to
kind of imagine is what if I don't
actually take all of my exploration
first and then make a choice but just
explore some proportion of the time so
every one out of ten units that I
interact with I'm gonna randomly choose
and for the other nine out of ten I'm
gonna choose whatever works best up to
that point in time so now I'm kind of
spreading out my exploration over the
whole population as opposed to moving
all of it to the front so make some
sense yeah so that's this idea of what
we call a greedy obviously here you can
dis to say oh how how large is this
probability of exploration B and and
maybe even should it always be the same
like should it be the same in the
beginning as it is by the time I get to
the end of that population which then
reasonably inspires different types of
policies where the amount of exploration
and exploitation just changes
continuously as you're getting more data
so one thing that's super reasonable and
it's what I'm kind of putting here on
the heading of Thompson sampling it's
this idea that I'm gonna choose these
actions with some probability that is
proportional to my belief into which
action has the highest payoff so if I'm
starting out and I don't know which
action is best and it's somewhat
invariant what I'm gonna do
it's just a sign a or B 50/50 like with
the probability of 1/2 because I don't
feel one is better than the other I
don't believe one is better than the
other now if I start collecting data and
a is paying off more than B what I'm
gonna do is just in
creates the probability of people seeing
a so I'm not never actually making this
deterministic decision between
exploration exploitation I'm just gonna
adapt my probabilities and make them
higher and higher as I feel that some
action is paying off more and more one
very easy way of doing this is in a
Bayesian framework and effectively just
sampling from your posterior and kind of
rewards for both of these two actions of
playing whichever is best this kind of
automatically implements this idea that
whatever you feel is best that's what
you're gonna play more um we have
frequentist
type strategies like this as well I
would say you see B's in some ways not
everybody would agree a kind of now
frequentist Thompson sampling in this
case so it's also effectively has this
behavior where if something performs
better you're gonna play it more often
so these are these different types of
strategy for the problem um and it's
interesting to see how they relate and
which one is better and one way of doing
that is comparing to actually having
full knowledge so knowing what I should
have chosen for everyone and then I can
compare these different strategies at
least in this theoretical setting in
terms of what's called regret how much
do I miss out when using this strategy
compared to doing the optimal strategy
which obviously in practice is not known
and you get things like this so higher
is worse in this case and you'd see that
the the a/b test so epsilon first moving
all the exploration first actually is
quite often somewhat depends on how you
set up the problem exactly and what
these probabilities are that's going to
determine how quickly these things are
gonna rise but by and large Thompson's
sampling and often epsilon VD are going
to outperform epsilon first and more
qualitatively this behavior of these
policies what you're seeing here is
gonna remain as is in the following
sense that if first always has this
linear increase in the beginning this is
when you're this is when you're kind of
just randomly trying so half of the time
you're gonna choose the wrong thing now
after your trial you're moving to the
guideline and depending on how large
your trial will be the probability of
making the right choice is going to
increase
but now since your decision is gonna be
made based on some finite sample there's
some nonzero probability that you make
the wrong choice so this is always gonna
still slope up a bit it's always slope
um
Epsilon greedy so this fixed proportion
of exploration well that's gonna
increase as your start gaining knowledge
but at some point it's also gonna linear
in the slope up because you had this
fixed probability of just choosing
randomly no strategies like Thompson's
sampling and
UCB will actually have this performance
that they keep on sloping down so to say
you keep on learning and you keep on
performing better and better at this
problem so if one thing and I'm not sure
how much of this was familiar to people
but thinking about this problem as they
can exploration exploitation problem I
think is useful and also just knowing
that the traditional a be test or
randomized control trial that we use all
the time might not actually be the most
optimal solution to this problem it
might be a very practical solution to
this problem either so don't get me
wrong maybe testing is nice in many ways
it's easy to implement in batches it's
also kind of something that people
understand so whatever your manager will
understand what you've just been doing
it's gonna be slightly trickier for
Thompson sampling but it's definitely
not the most effective solution in terms
of rewards cumulative rewards for these
types of problems now this was just to
arms a very than a simple set of subs
are kind of lost this idea of
personalization but in a sense most of
these results at least qualitatively
also just transfer to much more complex
situations complex situations where
instead of what we've now been doing is
kind of modeling the expected reward
that's a function of the action it's
just these two different means and so
you can think about what we have been
trying to do is estimate this model of
these two means of these two actions and
choosing the one with the highest means
as often as possible well if we're just
modeling the expected reward as a
function of the action there's nothing
really that permits or the prohibits us
from including this whole context from
increasing that action space and you
having a much larger in some ways it's a
supervised learning model in this sense
to predict the expected reward given
some action for a context that's given
to me and as long as I'm just adding
some exploration to that problem I can
actually do quite well so what you would
like to do is have a model that dictates
the relationship between context actions
onto the rewards and make sure you add
some exploration in the beginning you
would like lots of exploration and as
you go along and as your estimates
become more informed you want to slowly
decrease the amount of exploration
that's a very reasonable way of trying
to tackle this problem of
personalization when you have the
opportunity to experiment there with
some of the intuitions I want to give to
that problem and just highlight kind of
the interesting multi-armed bandit
problem and how well that kind of skills
to these types of applications um just
for those interested maybe some of you
are interested within my but in the lab
we've been doing a lot of kind of
applied evaluations of different bandit
policies in different contexts and one
of the things that happens if you think
about the policy like this effectively
it does two things one is given a
context it you know it gives you an
action the second thing you need to do
is given whatever rewards come back
potentially update my policy so
potentially update the logic that
dictates how I'm choosing my action so
those are effectively just two steps
that are generally applicable for many
of these problems that you could
formalize as a contextual bandit problem
so what we did is build I'd say quite an
extensive framework to allow people to
in kind of in an arrest fashion so as
kind of in a web server fashion
implement these two steps update a
policy and now give me an action in an
extensible framework where you can
easily plug and play these different
types of allocation policy so once
you've implemented this it's very easy
to experiment with different policies in
some contexts so that software might be
interested in
I guess what all those layers share some
of the slicer than you do and then
you'll have these links but from the lab
because this is something we've been
doing quite often we just want to share
some of this
we've been making to do this um so that
was the first bit of the talk thinking
about how to address this
personalization problem as a multi-armed
bandit problem when I have the kind of
somewhat unique opportunity to
experiment one by one and the main thing
is just oh as long as I have some good
model that is allowing me to predict the
expected value of each action given some
context and I add some exploration I can
actually do relatively well on that
problem however a much more common
conception of that problem I would say
it's the one where you receive some data
that contains in a sense you know
columns of context so it has a context
or a feature factor for each individual
unit it contains actions that have been
chosen by somebody else
not necessarily by you and some outcome
so when does this happen one place where
I see this happen a lot on where we do a
lot of work is in health care where we
look at electronic patient records or
look at registry data and effectively
what we see is the background of people
we see what their treatments are and we
see their outcome so we have a bunch of
that data and that's gonna be for a
subset of the whole population of units
now I want to create a good policy to
use on the remainder of these units yeah
so I wasn't necessarily in the luxury
position to sequentially learn but I
have some data what can we do in that
case
No well very simple example of this
would be a data set that looks something
like this
so I have meals and females have
treatment and control and have some
outcome sorry I just have a bunch of
these rows and I can start learning what
is the action that I should be taking
and one of the I would say fairly wrong
ways in which people are approaching is
if you're thinking about oh this is this
looks like very much a supervised
learning problem like this model that I
was come trying to do it's just a
supervised learning problem so I have
this data let me just fit this model and
learn
now even based on this very phrase you
know four rows of data learn that
control gives a higher reward than
treatment so I should be using control
now a very practical situation where you
actually find the result like this is
when you start thinking about the
treatment of breast cancer for women if
you look at the Dutch registry data in
breast cancer treatments and just look
at whether or not women received
chemotherapy you'll see that those women
that receives chemotherapy have a higher
probability of dying within the next
year than those that did not
so this is the actual data if you're
just looking at it um so in very naively
training a model just on those two means
for these two actions will dictate some
rule and the rule effectively would be
to not use chemotherapy no now any
oncologist will tell you quite simply
that this rule is wrong for the
following reason that what is happening
in the dataset is that only those women
that have a severe big tumor will get
surgery and subsequently chemotherapy
whereas if you have a small tumor
surgery is sufficient you won't get
chemotherapy so what's driving the
mortality in the year after is not the
treatment but it's actually the
properties of the tumor before the
treatment now those properties also
drive the choice of treatment so we have
what we would go in statistics a perfect
confound in this data set and this is
one of the tricky things that might
happen once you get a data set like this
um and really one way of summarizing
this in kind of the notation that Judea
Perl is using is this idea that whatever
model that I learned based on this data
so the relationship between the actions
and the outcomes is not necessarily the
same as a relationship between the
actions and the outcomes once I start
doing those so the actual causal effects
and it can the reason why this is the
case is because if you think about this
this breast cancer example it's because
some aspect of your context so in that
sense the severity of the tumor actually
dictates which action people take so
there's a probability of one for
specific action given a specific value
of the context propensity scores are
these known to people that's so okay so
we're venturing into some territory
people haven't seen before propensity
score being the probability of receiving
a specific treatment or action
conditional on your complex feature once
those are zeros or ones we have now
introduced perfect confounding and this
is really tricky because at that point
in time whatever supervised learning
solution you're going to try for this
answer might give you a totally wrong
answer might dictate a totally wrong new
policy to use on the remaining units so
we have to start thinking about these
propensity scores in some way and what I
find extremely interesting just in a
practical sense is that in the medical
world a lot of physicians are pushing
for more and more guidelines so for very
strict rules if the patient has this and
this and this we should always use this
treatment now those guidelines are very
useful if we know that they're actually
correct in the sense that we know that
those are the best action but if people
are using those very strictly
we're actually generating this type of
data so we're generating data in these
like electronic patient records that are
not going to be informative of any other
action than the ones that are actually
being done so how do we tackle this
problem
well there's I'd say conceptually two
situations one is where he might know
these propensity scores so we at least
know enough of the policy that was used
to collect the data to say something
about these propensities and in its
simplest case those propensities would
be just one half if it's two treatments
effectively what I'm doing then is just
a randomized experiment so that two
treatments the probability of each
treatment conditional on the context
factors you can be in a half well that
just means I'm just randomly assigning
these treatments to people well if
that's known we can do something that
was published a few years ago it's
called offline evaluation of these
policies and effectively it's very
simple conceptually how this works you
just step through these you know data
rows one by one you take your policy
which predicts some action you match it
to the action that's actually observed
in the data set if those match you
include that data point so you include
the reward and do whatever updating of
your policy you want
those don't mesh you just ignore it you
ignore that data set which means you get
an expectation N or n is the whole
population divided by two valid
observations of how your policy performs
this gives you an unbiased estimate of
the performance of your policy um and
this idea can be extended to situations
in which your propensity czar not
necessarily one half but they actually
do depend on the context or even
extended to include somewhat of the data
generating mechanism so if you already
know if you already have some idea of
what's driving the expected value of the
action given the context well these are
things you can also include and you get
to a recent area of the literature is
called doubly robust offline policy
evaluation but it's really just this
extension of these ideas as long as I
have some clue of how this data was
collected so what policy was driving the
collection I can kind of inversely
control for that and still evaluate
other types of policies we're using this
type of ideas for example in practice
when using data from a large randomized
study that's that's trying to see
whether aspirin or heparin to in effect
different painkillers administered to
people once they go into the emergency
ward after they had a cardiac arrest and
whether or not they die within two weeks
so there's a really big study out there
that's kind of randomizing these
different arms and what we're doing on
this data is using a lot of the
contextual features so background
information about these people and we're
trying to Train
or trying to see whether some
personalized policies would actually
fare better than just choosing whatever
arm works best so the general treatment
right now is aspirin because that's kind
of so the lower is better in this case
because it's people dying um we don't
want them to die the aspirin one is the
one that is actually now in the
guideline is what everybody gets once
they get in but doing personalized
policies so where these actions actually
depends on the context features can at
least an expectation lower that by about
two percent so this is just off line
policy evaluation as long as I know how
this data was collected I can now start
evaluating truly personalized assignment
schemes
clearly the whole thing becomes quite a
bit trickier if we don't know these
propensity scores evolve if we don't
know how data was generated no cuz now I
just have this data said it might have
this potential confounder
what can I still do well one reasonable
thing to do is to then say well let's
estimate these propensities based on my
data so instead of those being 1/2 or
whatever being something that I know
because I know the assignment policy
let's just try to learn the assignment
policy based on the data that I have
then if I've learned the assignment
policy I can still in first week and it
correct for it and evaluate all kinds of
different policies on this existing data
set that I have so that's something that
we're also doing and we're doing this on
a large kind of oncology data set so the
NCR that said the Dutch oncology
registry um and we're doing this for
colon rectal cancer where we have
effectively whether or not people are
receiving chemotherapy their outcomes
within two or five years and a whole
bunch of contextual feature of these
people and they're we're trying to learn
with different correction methods
because obviously you can do different
models for these propensity scores you
can do different main models we're
trying to see if we can correct um and
there we're in the luxury situation that
there is also a large randomized control
trial so now what we can do is see if
the policy of a randomized control trial
of which we learn the outcome on this
observational data matches the outcomes
of the true randomized control trial now
so now we actually have two data sets
one is generated in a way that we know
one is generated in a way that we don't
necessarily know because it's it's
really this observation all data in the
world and what we try to do is implement
the policy of the one that we know on
the one that we don't know and see if
they match now the match being these and
a confidence bars these yellow ones and
and effectively what you see is that
with relatively flexible models it is
based in additive regression tree models
for both the propensity score and the
mean model so using W robust evaluation
we can get two estimates that are
extremely close to the registry data the
other side of it though is that some of
these things don't really work
very well-liked if we're not controlling
for them we can get very very different
estimates and here we're in the lucky
situation that we can check but in many
cases you won't be use have a data
setting you can start doing all of this
fancy W robust whatever evaluation um
but it's gonna be really really hard to
tell or to guarantee that whatever
you're estimating is the outcome of the
policy that you're evaluating is
actually gonna materialize in real life
and clearly to kind of answer or solve
this problem based on observational data
one of the key ingredients which i think
is an extremely fascinating field that's
kind of developing over the last few
years well if I would know the actual
underlying causal structure involved
that was generating this data then I
would be able to solve kind of this
offline policy evaluation problem based
on observational data if in some way I
could learn the causal structure I'm I'm
not going to talk about that too much
because I'm always running out of time
but what I find tremendously interesting
as a research direction now is how can
we use causal discovery mechanism so
causal discovery either by virtue of
conditional independencies such as you
know proposals by puerile or more
extensions of the such computational
complexity approaches to discovering
causal causal relationships how can we
combine those with this kind of offline
policy evaluation I think that's an
awesome direction that we're now trying
to venture into um so I hope this kind
of highlighted some of the cool things I
think if you start thinking about
personalization which in a sense is this
very simple problem of just doing the
you know doing the right thing for each
and every person that sounds super
intuitive and super easy that this is
actually an extremely hard problem which
touches on sequential learning it sort
of the kind of a reinforcement learning
problem it touches on causal inference
it's a really rich problem to study um
so I hope that's not somewhat of
interested to people for doing all these
plots that you were just looking at
we've actually developed an art package
for easy offline evaluation of bandit
policies so again we'll share the links
but that's also available and sorry it's
in our I don't know
like Superstock on fighting here you
know yeah so there we go
um so that's there and I just want to
close off with a few closing remarks so
what I've tried to do is highlight the
idea that personalization is a super
interesting and rich theoretical problem
to study theoretical with obvious
practical applications um that if you're
in the luxury situation to experiment
sequentially what you want to think
about on one hand is making an effective
mean model so a model dictate what is
the outcome of my action for the contact
but on the other hand you want to make
sure you're exploring and so many
tuitions as to oh when I have relatively
limited data I want to explore a lot and
by the time that I'm actually moving to
having more and more informed models I
want to stop exploring or at least
decrease exploration I hope those
intuitions are clear on the other hand I
hope that from the second hand of the
talk second part it's also clear that if
you are doing this so if you're have
this luxury of sequentially
experimenting then it would be nice if
you actually store the probabilities of
what you're doing like your policy at
that point in time why because then
you're storing these propensity scores
so in effect you're storing a summary of
the policy that was collecting your data
which now you'll be able to use to
evaluate all kinds of other policies of
line so you're allowing yourself to
learn in the future so that's what I
strongly encourage people to do and I
also strongly encourage people to be
very skeptical of people that don't
which effectively are those people that
now and this is kind of starting to
become quite common practice especially
in the health domain where people take
electronic patient records or just
registry data fit a supervised learning
model often a very complex model choose
some actions based on that model and say
that they've just learned the best
individual personalized action for each
and every person involved and I hope by
now everybody is very well aware that
that might not necessarily be the case
and actually it's super hard to give any
guarantees on the performance of what
you have just did without being
extremely careful about the causal
assumptions and the assumptions about
the kind of
the data collection policy without
making any of those that so I'm just
going to be extremely tricky to
guarantee that even the sign of what
you're doing is correct like even the
sign of the treatment effect is going to
be correct that little beep was kind of
telling me to shut up so this was my
time and I kind of you know that's my
last slide so that all kind of Mexico
thank you so much for your attention if
there's any questions raise your hands
let me know yeah thanks
[Applause]